si has practicado y espero también
memorizado las tablas de multiplicación
te habrás dado cuenta que ya estás listo
para poder hacer cualquier
multiplicación simplemente debes
entender el sistema de cómo se hace pero
no solo te voy a enseñar el sistema te
voy a enseñar por qué funciona y eso es
lo interesante es es la base es lo más
profundo de todo esto entonces iniciemos
con una multiplicación que tal vez tú
digas yo no voy a poder hacer esto pero
me a 16 por 9 crees que lo puedes hacer
yo creo que sí simplemente con lo que ya
sabes sabes otras tablas de multiplicar
tal vez no te sepas la tabla del 16 pero
te sabes que la del 9 la del 6 la del 1
entonces perfecto vamos a arrancar con
esto se resuelve de la siguiente manera
ok
primero multiplicas este 9 por el número
que está en las unidades entonces 9 por
6 sabes lo que es 9 por 6 ok si no sabes
memoriza lo aquí lo voy a poner 9 por 6
es igual a 54 eso tengo siempre muy
presente entonces pones al 54 de la
siguiente manera
4 lo pones aquí abajo en el lugar de las
unidades y el 5 va aquí arriba aquí va
el 5 como como cuando sumas ajá y tienes
un número extra entonces lo pones ahí
arriba y luego multiplicamos 9 x 19 por
1 cuánto es eso es 9 ajá eso es muy
directo 1 por cualquier cosa es
cualquier cosa uno por cuatro es 41 por
55 1 por 99 por 1 es igual a 9 entonces
tenemos este 5 aquí arriba por lo tanto
al 9 por 1 le sumamos ese 5 tenemos 9
por 15 y que obtenemos aquí entonces le
sumó 5 y tenemos 14 estos 95 es igual a
14 y ese 14 lo ponemos acá abajo
entonces ahí lo tienes 16 por 9 es igual
a 144 ahora si tú sabes la tabla del 12
en 12 por 12 es igual a 144
pero pero bueno no sé si lo puedes ver
sólo con sabe estos dos datos lo
lograron cierto entonces no necesitabas
tener en tu memoria la tabla de 16 no
ahora porque funciona todo esto te lo
voy a explicar voy a volver a escribir
estos dos números acá abajo entonces lo
voy a hacer
puedo reescribir el 16 como como 10 más
6 10 más 6 es igual a 16 esto es 16 y 9
lo pongo aquí entonces ahora haré la
multiplicación pongo el signo de
multiplicación y primero quiero
multiplicar 9 por 6 ahora por porque
luego de esta manera por qué porque
estoy separando lo que está en las
unidades y lo que esté en el lugar de
las décimas entonces este uno está en la
segunda columna ajá no es un 1 es un 10
entonces es un 10 más 6 porque lo hice
de esta manera así que hagamos esto
hacemos lo mismo
9 por 6 9 por 6 es igual a 54 pero en
lugar de escribir 54 lo escribiré a 54
es igual a 50 + 4 entonces 9 por 6 es
igual a 50 más 4
perfecto entonces esta es mi columna de
las unidades y aquí puedo poner el 4
aquí va el 4 más bien dicho pero creo
que voy a hacer con el 50 debe ponerlo
en algún lugar cierto y lo debo poner en
esta columna entonces por convenio lo
pongo acá arriba aquí arriba lo pongo el
50 aquí sólo puse un 5 porque estaba
posicionando lo en el lugar de las
décimas un 5 aquí realmente significa 50
y un 1 es un 10 entonces bueno pero
ahora lo separo para que veas que son 50
y 10 ahora dice que es 9 por 10 que es 9
por 10 9 por 10 ya lo sabes 10 por
cualquier cosa es simplemente
en 9 por cualquier número es el número y
un 0 entonces 9 por 10 es igual a 90 y
después le vamos a sumar este 50
entonces 90 más 50 eso a que es igual
esto es esto es igual a 140 jaja
entonces 9 por 10 es igual a 90 más 50
es igual a 140 y 140 lo podemos
reescribir como 100 más 40 ahora lo que
haré es poner el 40 aquí en esta columna
y el cielo puedo poner a no importa
realmente puede ser aquí abajo acá
arriba o lo pongo aquí arriba o lo puedo
poner acá abajo no no pasa nada lo voy a
poner aquí simplemente quiero que veas
que está en esta columna esta columna
ahí va el 100 por lo tanto nuestra
respuesta es 100 más 44 eso es igual a
144 perfecto ahí ves es lo mismo
entonces espero espero te haya gustado y
lo hayas encontrado razonable la
explicación intentemos otro ejercicio
vale entonces ejemplos ejemplos y más
ejemplos es la base de todo lo que
intentemos 55 x 8 55 x 8 y vamos a
iniciar con esto entonces iniciamos con
el el 88 por 5 eso es igual a 40
ya lo sabes esto es igual a 40
el 0 lo ponemos aquí abajo en esta
columna ahí va al 0 y el 4 va acá arriba
jaja entonces otra vez 5 por 8 es 40 y
44 es 44 la respuesta es 440 puedes
hacer lo mismo que dicen en el ejemplo
pasado entonces 50 más 5 y luego el 8
pero hagamos otro ejemplo entonces lo
haré voy a voy a elegir un color un
color este me parece lindo espero te
guste también a ti perfecto que entonces
aunque digamos que yo tengo digamos que
tengo 78 por por 7 vale entonces por 7
ahora 8 por 7 es igual a 56 entonces lo
escribo acá 8 por 7 es igual a 56 el 6
lo ponemos aquí y el 5 acá arriba 7 por
7 es 49 7 por 7 es igual a 49 y le
sumamos este 5 entonces vamos a sumarle
el 5 y eso qué es eso es igual a 5
47 por 7 es igual a 49 5 es igual a 54
546 es la respuesta y tal vez hace de 10
minutos tú decías yo nunca voy a poder
hacer eso no que haré de mi vida pero
ver si lo podemos hacer y sin saber la
tabla del 78 no es necesario memorizar
todas las tablas del universo efe
entonces bueno sigamos con más ejemplos
qué te parece si hacemos 89 por hay unos
fácil por 3
entonces 89 por 33 por 9 es igual a 7
las aves 3 por 9 es igual a 27 7 valen
las unidades y este 2 va acá arriba en
like en las décimas entonces sería 20
727 es 20 7 ok ahora 3 por 8 3 por 8 es
igual a 24 24
entonces sumamos este 2 ahora obtengo 26
24 2 es igual a 26 267 como total
entonces hagamos hagamos otro otro
ejemplo pero un poco más difícil vale
justo cuando te empezabas a sentir
cómodo pero no no no yo soy yo soy
malvada entonces vamos a hacer un poco
un poco difícil para que te sientas
incómodo 239 por qué te parece por 6 por
6 entonces vamos tú puedes no no no
parece este vídeo vamos a seguir con
estos valientes entonces 9 por 6 eso es
ahora lo voy a hacer acá entonces es el
mismo procedimiento es el mismo
procedimiento ok voy a poner aquí a 6
por 9 6 por 9 es igual a 54 ya lo
sabíamos esto el 4 va aquí abajo y el 5
acá en el lugar de las décimas 54 de 54
ahora
6 por 3 6 por 3 esto es igual a 18 18 y
tenemos el 5 entonces sumamos ese 5 18 +
5 6 por 3 es igual a 18 más 5 es igual a
23 23 ahora bien sólo para dejarlo en
claro no multiplicamos 6 por 3 y sumamos
5 no lo que hicimos fue os observe este
este lugar esta posición esto es un 36
por 30 más 50 entonces 39 es igual a 39
este número el 23 el número 23 aunque
aunque yo dije 6 por 3 es igual a 18 más
el 5 es igual a 23
este número es realmente 230 ajá ponemos
el 3 en el lugar de las décimas entonces
voy a voy a cambiar de color ahí está
este mejor entonces este 23 pongo el 3
en el lugar de las décimas y este este
otro lo pongo acá el 2 lo pongo arriba
ahora ya casi terminamos 11
una última multiplicación 6 por 2 6 por
2 es está fácil eso es igual a 12 más
este 2
entonces sumamos el 2 12 2 es igual a 14
cierto entonces tenemos 6 por 2 es igual
a 12 más el 2 es igual a 14 y pongo el 4
acá abajo ajá si hubiera un un dígito
más acá pondría el 1 acá arriba pero no
no hay ya no hay dígitos entonces pongo
el 1 hay también abajo por lo tanto por
lo tanto 239 por 6 es igual a 1.434 ok
hagamos otro el último el último ahí voy
a hacerle un poco difícil 1 1 de 4
dígitos ok perfecto entonces uno de
cuatro dígitos prepárate prepárate
mentalmente 7.362 por qué te parece si
por 9
entonces hago algo esto directo no voy a
hacer ya las sumas y multiplicaciones
por otro lado no así directo entonces
directo 9 por 2 es igual a 18 18 ahora 9
por 6 eso es igual a 54 54 1 eso es
igual a 55 55 ok perfecto 9 por 3
eso es 27 más el 5 entonces 27 más 5 es
igual a 32 32 entonces lo voy a escribir
aquí y aquí va el 2
el 2 va aquí y acaba el 3 y ahora 9 por
7 eso es igual a 63 3 366 ajá pero aquí
voy a poner abajo el 6 y como ya no hay
dígitos pongo pongo el 6 abajo y otros 6
también entonces tengo aquí 66 y tenemos
ya la respuesta 7.362 por 9 es igual a
66 mil 258 perfecto lo logramos